it was on Monday the 23rd of March
nearly seven weeks ago the Boris Johnson
first announced a lockdown and urged us
all to stay at home and save lives
at that stage 336 people in this country
had died in hospital because of Cove in
nineteen the reproduction or re at the
start of the epidemic was three so if
every one person infected three more
were infected and then three more
infected after them and so on as
lockdown came into force the our rate
fell to around naught point six but
because of virus was already
exponentially growing the number of
deaths continued to rise on the 21st of
April 1172 deaths were recorded in a
single day but as the our rate fell in
time so too did the daily numbers of
deaths today 269 deaths were recorded
the our rate is now thought to stand
somewhere between naught point five and
nine point nine in the community the
outbreak is shrinking fast but in
hospitals and particularly care homes
the virus has continued to spread which
is why that reproduction rate might have
risen slightly and whilst cases have
been falling and the our rate is still
low there is very little flexibility
before we start to see the numbers
exponentially rising again we've got a
very narrow opportunity in the next few
weeks to keep control as they are not
the infectivity of the virus at the same
time getting society back to some
version of normal if we screw up the
virus will continue to labor along there
and make us go back into lock now and
then come out again and go back that's
not what we want we've got to do it in a
controlled way as soon as a number of
people one person infects rises above
one Cove in nineteen becomes very hard
to contain if that number is below one
the virus isn't being sufficiently
spread to sustain an outbreak easing
lockdown and keeping that our rate low
will be a big challenge for the
government